I'm such a fan I have I've tried to keep
my cool today but I've been like last
time I saw Sasha I was a guest on drag
race and I was just floored it was like
episode three but I was like
um I think she's gonna be okay
drag's biggest stars are teaming up with
country Superstar and lgbtq plus
Advocate maren Morris for a powerful
conversation in billboard magazine yes
Sasha Colby my call me mother co-star
land Insider Eureka O'Hara and Simone
join Marin on the cover of Billboard's
Pride issue where they share why
everyone should be paying attention to
the anti-lgbtq plus legislations how
have you come to terms with the number
of anti-lgbtq bills passing through the
state legislatures around the country I
hope that people become educated from
the round table they see that we're
humans and I hope that people open their
minds and their hearts and realize that
we deserve to be happy loved and to live
our lives just like you and I've seen
this reference made a lot it's just like
the Mrs Doubtfire reference where it's
it's hilarious if it's a assist male in
drag then it's like okay for the kids to
see but you know God forbid you see
someone truly expressing themselves and
entertaining and just being free so
upset because that's what's really
happening it's about how we express
ourselves that's about the youth
deciding because we have the queerest
youth we've ever had right now and
that's what they're mad about people may
think now that it's just the drag queens
it's just trans people if they can do it
to them they can do it to anybody else
where the most important thing to do I
mean of course blah blah blah we scream
that all day every day the most
important thing to do is
take care of the people around you that
aren't being watched after yeah be an
active Ally when it matters be an ally
outside of the clear spaces there's so
many fake allies out there they do it
for the cloud or the image but for the
month of June right right look it's so
important to be an active Ally like
Marin not just during Pride but all year
the drag artist took the time to embrace
the impact drag has had on pop culture
as well as shout out some celebs who
have been helping shed more light on the
art form how do you think drag
ultimately influences our pop culture
itself
we used to be a mirror like in the 70s
80s 90s we would mirror pop culture and
now we get to be pop culture and be the
taste makers We Are Who celebrities
designers artists are inspired yeah true
no longer in the dark yeah and I was I
saw something Melissa McCarthy she did
doing Ursula and I saw she sell at the
premiere she said I sold everything I I
know from a drag queen and then she
admitted it and that is the truth of
life you know he was a Divine
impersonator for years before she got
her action where I come so I mean we're
everything and Dolly has said like you
know if she wasn't Dolly Parton she'd be
a drag queen it's it's elevated to a
level because I mean especially when I'm
going into Glam for an event I'm looking
at a lot of y'all's photos
the round table discussion also touched
on the topic of protecting kids from
drag artists if you don't want to go to
drugstore don't go to drive right if you
don't want to have your kids or
Direction yeah and it's just that simple
you don't take your kids to a rated a
movie because you don't want them to see
it you don't take your kids to the
direction it's really simple don't also
tell other parents what to do with their
kids you know it's not a one size
fits-all like conveyor belt of parenting